thank you
drone and body camera footage show the
moments leading up to a deadly shooting
in Northern California after a suspect
wanted on charges of child molestation
came at police with a knife
February 14th in the town of Dunagan
that's about 40 minutes Northwest of
Sacramento at about eight o'clock that
morning the Yolo County SWAT team
arrived at 63 year old Hector Perez's
trailer to serve an arrest warrant on
child molestation related charges in the
past Perez was convicted of assaulting a
police officer because of his History of
Violence officials from multiple
departments including a crisis
negotiation team responded
for four hours officials tried to get in
contact with Perez yelling to him from
outside the trailer and calling people
he knew eventually they used a drone to
get a better look at his trailer without
harming any of his neighbors through
that Drone footage officials confirmed
Perez was inside
you need to come step outside of the
trailer with your hands up and surrender
to police now after that Yolo County
officials used a robot to break inside
the trailer and get a better look around
body camera video shows First Responders
also using a pull camera to search for
Perez
somebody help me with the visual here
owlette that bathroom looks it
see a sink keep going it looks
I'll watch it for you a lot of blood in
the sink right no no that's an optical
light that's a light fixture I'm not
seeing anybody in this room small what
about the tub
is a tub to the left right here the
shower let me get the back step
it's
this way yeah I'm working on that as
officials use the camera to search
through Perez's trailer he begins
pulling on it try to get into the shower
itself
he's yanking on it he's in there
show me your hands
contact he is uh hey hold him
hey
go back
go back to a vehicle
Yolo County officials say Perez still
did not comply after grabbing the camera
they then used an armored vehicle to
approach the trailer's front door one
officer threw a phone inside his trailer
in an effort to communicate but Perez
did not use it that's when officers used
CS gas as another tactic to get Perez
outside
yeah
at about 12 35 PM officials say Perez
finally exited the trailer they report
his clothes were bloody and he was
carrying a knife officers can be heard
calling for Perez to show his hands
before firing a less Lethal Weapon
this video shows another angle of the
less Lethal Weapon being fired
when Perez still does not drop the
weapon an officer opens fire
shots fired shots fired when Perez left
the trailer with the knife he walked in
the direction of an officer posted
behind a propane tank three more
officers were located behind a nearby
tree after the shooting Perez dropped
the knife near the front of his trailer
that's when officials began performing
life-saving measures
nearby paramedics responded to the
shooting but Perez was pronounced dead
on the scene the shooting is now under
investigation by the Davis Police
Department the Yolo County district
attorney is overseeing it to determine
whether use of force was justified in
the shooting reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie